okay and please get out dad it now New
Zealand um oh ok ok just the gals ladder
I'm taking barely to the Dead Island I'm
of the picture ok ok ok I really see a
difference in here ok I just a snap it's
ok ok ok ok oh very nice background
music as get such as I ok video I just
called the video it's god god is god got
it I got it yes gotta cut good ok don't
know why this is doing this again and ok
get ready to play a new game yes ok and
play this oh he's a throwing expert um
she's a firearms expert and this is
sharp weapon expert I'm more of a
firearm kinda guy in a sand and I hate
with jostles ok which is [ __ ] ironic
since i'm expected to put my bloody life
on the line for them ok that's what they
pay me for this pricey hoteli to be a
bodyguard for the rich and famous
[ __ ] who come to Binoy to blow their
money ok i used to be a cop bloody good
one a vice detective incident ok you
know how many female half Aborigine
detectives there were before me none ok
ok do you think it was easy suffering
the abuse of my so-called colleagues
half of them hated me because I was a
girl and the other half didn't like the
fact that my mum was occurring Oh
I busted my ass it took me 12 years to
make detective and that still wasn't
enough it's an old boys club you know
the whole justice system is a [ __ ]
joke teenage drug addicts hit put away
forever and all white wankers who steal
[ __ ] millions free that thinks he's
gonna talk much bugger i investigated
was clearly molesting his 14 year old
daughter but he had too much pull with
the politicians so i couldn't touch him
after the girl killed herself I
confronted him but he just locked her he
pulled out a pistol returned he could
blow my bleeding head off and no one
would care because I was nothing and no
bucket I'm just you know I can't can I
go ahead that's as all the same oh nice
on a nice serene environment
yeah my Gran's and I like
Oh a nice little hotel of it wow this is
a really nice looking place ok people
are like upset or so oh nice towels get
good um Oh what is this it's a med kit
sixteen dollars I had to pay for that
what is just like a mini bar he thinks
what're you pay for it ok i guess i
guess a Scott side I will not let me
Sidney M or anything f ok um that's just
little weird I guess can I take this
I can't Oh mother says it's always worth
taking a look six dollars six dollars
nothing up magazine hope sec I'm just
going to quickly quickly I mean when I
say quit I mean quick what the heck
[ __ ] s had it help how speech volume
methods too high okay very good
okay um yes yes what's in this sorry sir
sorry I'm just trying to get an artery
know like I can very nice yes yes this
is des okay okay money's is good i guess
still in the apocalypse right like he's
so use this okay hey just listen like
she even shows an apocalypse or if she
just like stealing things okay okay I
guess I'm just stealing at this point
oops that's cool something like that
let's see here room service room service
I'm trying to just at stake cool flood
Lee do you have anything any to claim
now I guess right like you're all pretty
clean people no complaints you know you
guys tip well okay once again I
I Charlie find a lobby maybe there's
something we can use dialect miss a
gigantic cutscene or something cuz this
is a little just unexplainable you know
jesus is our so much money
you know beautiful beautiful
oh wow that's sexy okay yeah that's fine
i guess i just like it's just more shop
little thing Chucky there mykola alright
keep me out of the money system at ease
I got a phone yeah i got my [ __ ] fun
yeah I can't jump yeah I'm trip over
that no I don't like that
okay looks it looks like i'm gone
elevator it's scary about that see
flashlight
what oh I own objective I don't even see
the map my bad guys scary [ __ ] open it
like what do you mean oh oh okay I can't
tell you how he hasn't been in this
situation
yeah great let's say the camera uh-huh
sir won't reduce myself liner right now
we gotta get a hilly entities doing
safely a sauce I ok gonna have to trust
me first you need to get hold of a
weapon search in the maintenance storage
room or the end of the corridor I would
move if I were you now okay how do I get
out of it up control can't hurt to look
like you turn a move but it's not a
money here so [ __ ]
that is just so unnecessary I won our
way
yeah well that one's like so fat
this is scary game Jesus oh [ __ ] Oh
hassle that sir hello sir
oh Jesus this is a hang out like this is
a club all right this has no skill of
China dang head-nodding an addict
now this [ __ ]
execution
hey
yes like this Wow Oh cat gut gut gut I
can't get get get yeah yeah
just die out there
ah here's that going out there
you at least have a weapon and now me
you find a weapon
ok it son [ __ ] crazy on 3 123
ok
this is not going well so far I would
say
okay as I hi dad okay yes good good this
is sucking nuts hey sky his guy
Adam good yep ok likes mice okay can we
get hey